[Music]
um I come home from school and it just
seemed like this day I was just pick
pick I was picked on in every class in
the Halls you know people ah hey man
they were repeating me stuttering
and so this particular day I just had
enough I went home I was crying I was
like Mama how do I talk like this right
how do I stop this how can I fix this
have you ever felt like the underdog and
you don't have the confidence to do
something amazing and you want to
overcome that find out on this episode
of LED live
hey everybody Welcome to LED live today
is a very awesome a testimony that
you're gonna hear my friend Emmanuel
Smith and uh you are a personal chef so
this is kind of a neat story because
you've had to overcome some serious
challenges in life and it's really one
of those things that like when I hear a
story like this it gets me excited
because I think all of us at some point
in our life have felt like we can't do
this or we can't do that and so to see
somebody that's actually against a lot
of odds been able to achieve what you're
achieving is really neat so you guys are
going to love this Emmanuel welcome to
the show thank you thank you so tell us
a little bit about yourself
from Memphis Tennessee
I was raised in a my parents were
together up until I was about three
and so I never re remember my dad being
in the home but we did have a close
relationship happy child uh I didn't
know all the things going on so you know
it was all fine
um I think I was a extrovert as a child
I like to talk and be a prime you know
not really shy I would say until I was
probably about
six so what kind of made you flip from
being like you know super outgoing
wanting to engage with everybody to just
sort of more reserved
um I think it came with my speech
um I used to Shredder as a child I mean
like really bad
um now as a young child you did not
stutter at all no I I can only remember
when I began to talk really good like
about you know five or six and
um
kind of developed from there and the
thing about it is I didn't know that it
was something bad or or I was actually
messing up with my speech until people
children they will let you know oh yes
you really can be awfully honest
sometimes yes too honest yeah and so
um I used to cut her and so I would say
now I stammer and so the difference in
stuttering and stammering and this is my
opinion
um stuttering is kind of like a machine
gun like this
Dameron is like you're trying to catch a
football but you can't quite catch it
you're almost there but you can't quite
get it um you don't get stuck because
you're actually moving but scattering is
like that machine gun just keeps on
going and and sometimes you have to kind
of like change the word right if you're
stuttered et cetera and then he's like
you come up with a different word to get
past that yeah and so
um not until I begin to go to school
um me I'm I'm still that extrovert I'm
talkative I'm trying to be funny you
know I'm that outgoing person and so
children begin to uh you know point and
yeah
and so they repeat
what I'm trying to speak
and with me I don't see any problem
until it's
I'm like why are they laughing and it's
like it's because of my speech what's
wrong with my speech Soul so now I see a
problem with my speech which makes me go
to an introvert so then you kind of just
grew up like not wanting to engage in a
in a in a public way or yeah especially
in a public way I was more like private
like you know with your friends I'm not
shy when it comes to them and
interesting enough when it came to girls
I would not stutter interesting very
interesting I could not explain it but
so you would go through waves kind of
like like not a problem and then you
know it was more accentuated in certain
times yeah
I I think I feel more comfortable you
know talking to girls because you know
uh you know you have to you know plan it
out yeah yeah you're thinking about it
uh this right here yeah yeah what's your
name can I get you now you know so it's
a school script and so uh I felt more
comfortable interesting I didn't feel
the pressure you know he would think
that I would feel more pressure with
that and so public just growing up in
church giving the scriptural hating uh
killing up in class to to speak oh I you
dreaded it yes I did not know had I had
anxiety
as a child I was dressed and it all came
when I would open up my mouth to speak
even
um uh answering the phone even giving my
name I would just
it was just horrible and I would call it
uh one time in particular I remember
this like it was yesterday
um I come home from school and it just
seemed like this day I was just pick
pick I was picked on in every class in
the Halls you know people ah hey man
they would repeat me stuttering
and so this particular day I just had
enough I went home I was crying I was
like Mama how do I talk like this why
how do I stop this how can I fix it so
my mama would say hey just just take
your time you know
but uh there was no speech therapy is
there a way that you can like learn too
yeah okay yes definitely
um people think that it's hereditary
it's a learned
it's kind of a learned thing
um had I found out in my research is
that
um the way you speak is you're taught by
your parents or who whoever is hazing
you and so my mom talked very fast very
fast she don't talk that fast now but as
a child she talked very fast and if a
child is Cur if they're corrected too
much when it's not time for them to
speak
um I would say
um not perfectly but it's the when that
the the development of their speech you
know is not as soon as they can talk you
know because there's there's still
you're still learning you're probably
still making those connections down the
road yeah and so you should give that
child time to really the hell up you
know correct them here and there and I
think that mixed with me trying to
emulate how my mom speak and then me
trying to um
trying to speak perfectly or to what I
thought was Perfection right and so not
until people begin to point it out oh
you why do you talk like this everybody
else speaks perfectly that's what made
me go to I'm not speaking right so I
would try to speak like everybody else
without knowing the different steps and
things that you can do you just really
tried to focus on it and so you yeah so
so how what did that do to you like you
know friend wise or you know did you did
you did you go through a series of
depression and because of my personality
people attract to me you know and um and
so
your parents don't care you know and I'm
like hey you messed up right here right
no yeah I don't care you know I was
still a fun having person but when it
came to speaking
giving a story and it's a group of
friends I would kind of sat down like
man if and I'm you know how you're
harder on yourself yeah than other
people yeah so I would go through this
Ang question of man if I say this let
this ladder this word
are they laughing with me or at me you
know you know it's it's a terrible thing
these days that you know bullying and
and being made fun of and things seems
to be getting worse and worse and worse
every year that passes by I I think it's
probably been going on forever I mean
this is not a new you know they've made
movies since the beginning of you know
the 1900s and shown that this was kind
of like something that people did in
schools but you really you you really
feel for kids that either have a little
something different or you know and
um I I remember growing up I always
tried to be friends with with everybody
you know I wasn't the kid who was
actually making fun of the other kids
and
um so I don't know if that helped me not
necessarily like you know have a bad
experience
um with that but my kids I try to tell
them that all the time you know there's
there's of course always kids in in the
school that maybe aren't up to speed or
something else and it's like man go to
that person and tell them you know that
you appreciate something that they it or
you know single them out and be friends
with those people because you know I can
imagine the the stress that that puts
someone through when it's just like you
know it's not your fault yeah not until
people started to point it out more so
children that I'm like I have a problem
you know yeah I didn't think it I'm
talking I'm chattering it doesn't affect
me until
um people begin to say
um you know hey um
or they're trying to correct you or
they're laughing at you and so there's a
way to to do it
um did you grow up in church oh yeah
yeah yes definitely so you had a
connection to God like were you were you
praying Lord take this away from me what
is this oh the all the time
hey if it didn't get taken away at the
moment did that have an impact upon your
your sort of beliefs yeah well no I just
feel like well this is my my my life
this isn't what it is I asked chatter
and that's me
um and so
um I just went through life just I'm I'm
the type of person where I like to solve
problems
so I'm like okay I'm a stutter so let me
figure out praise to get around it you
know s words
CH words
heard same word is hard and so I would
go okay instead of saying like I I just
had it down to a science but I still
stuttered so I was kind of self had a
Cadence and so um
so okay
um school was
tough yes yeah buried so moving into
adult life
um did you kind of find like you know a
way to really work with it or did you
seem like you you kind of were creeping
more into reclusive behaviors or yes
um when I graduated from high school I
just had this Epiphany let me see what
what this is how to overcome it
so I find a book I could not tell you
the name of it of that book but it
speaks about different celebrities
that's better and I'm like yeah this
person this person James Earl Jones
they're able to overcome it on camera
yes and in the book they're given the
things that they did to overcome it so
I'm like wow so I'm I'm practicing and
so I I stopped it this one it was James
Earl Jones
um
he said that he would put marbles in his
mouth and try to talk
he would go in front of the the mirror
and just re just repeat and just see him
himself talk
and so then it came to did you attempt
that oh yes everything
some of it is so I got stuck on the part
where they said tell your family tell
your friends tell your co-workers if you
do work
uh that you were trying to work on your
speech and you're going to talk very
slowly I was like I can't do that
because you know it's the society is
true
I show order you can be
um
my or like I I I just felt that I
couldn't talk that slow and so I put the
book down I'm done with them
but I did take away I have to I have to
speak
so I said well I'ma just speak to
everybody people in the store the
cashiers if I go to get cash out just
speak you know how you doing how's your
day so I think that helped me
tremendously because you realize when in
it hopefully in an adult setting it's a
little bit different than a kid setting
but most people will will you know they
may recognize you know that you have a
bit of a speech um thing but but they're
not gonna fault you for it kind of like
be mean to because of it at least I hope
most people are right yeah so you find
that people can be friendly even in that
situation and and
um you know coming up to somebody with
that confidence I think you know changes
it oh yeah yeah it happened and so uh
from there I I think the hell was this
the spark that made things change now
I'm not in school anymore so I don't
have to deal with no right there's no
pressure of like popularity and yeah
yeah I I would say the worst experience
in high school oh man I remember this
day so it's
um graduation
the first day of it and so um
the the music teacher came up with this
wild idea I will record each student to
give a speech oh no it's like nightmare
anxiety on 20. oh wow and so I tell them
like you know hey I started and I don't
want to do it I'm not comfortable I
don't know it's okay so we go through
take one horrible we go through take two
horrible we go to take three horrible
that's it I'm like what what yeah wait
that's it no no no no it tastes like no
it's okay and I'm like this is going to
be very bad oh no so graduation
night so just think yeah you're
stressing out all the way up to this
night
I'm like man
I hope he because I tell them please do
not play mine just let it be silenced
I'm okay with it so graduate so here's
the setting you have your uh fellow
classmates you have their families
I have my family and friends
so it came to my turn they common they
called my uh my name and so each student
would just go to their family and care
about flowers hmm
so as soon as mine started I was just
like
oh Lord please speed this up this is
hard and it seemed like I stumbled over
every word that I said that was the most
embarrassing moment in high school
and so I was like never again will I
record my me speaking no yeah which is
interesting because you know with
editing a lot of times people see
something and you don't realize how many
times that thing has been done you're
only seeing the end result and so you
know that's why you look at movie stars
and you just go you know these guys are
just nailing this yeah
30 times a lot of times you know so
exactly so that was that was the worst
but after I I graduated I kind of took
it up for myself to
figured this this thing out and so at
that time I didn't understand
oh I still kept thinking it's her it's
her editory you know and so I'm like
well since it is let me try to figure
out someone some ways and I'll
oftentimes the things that we're afraid
of you have to kind of do it to get over
it it sounds strange but that's true I
was afraid to to speak but the more I
spoke the better it became the more
confidence yes and the better that it
came yeah you know I I found that true
to a certain extent with like things
that I struggled with in my life it was
like the more that I spoke about them
and the more that I actually like was
able to address that verbally that that
ultimately helped me overcome those
things and you know it's like yeah you
know if you just kind of tuck it away
and hide it it's like you know it's hard
to deal with it but sometimes the best
is just bring it right out front yeah
and they they often talk about that with
people that have like a disability and a
missing arm or something like this I had
a family member that actually had his
his arm was busy to hear and I always
remember as a kid he was just a little
bit younger than me but but the first
thing he would do is he would reach out
and he would like like shake your hand
or show you and and it was like his way
of sort of just like laying it on the
table right on the front and just being
like hey wow you know that's so true so
um I get through high school I'm parking
and I I go through all of that and so I
turned 30 and I'm like
I know what I did when I was 19 but let
me go deeper
so I decided to do more research time
has passed it's been a decade after this
and I find out that it's not her
predatory yeah it has everything to do
with the development of your speech as a
child interesting so like a little
window when you're a child something
transpired there is it yeah
interesting and then from there you
emulating
and so what if for for me my mom spoke
too fast so I was trying to emulate her
even though I'm patterning and so the so
I'm not trying to
you for real have to slow down your
speech and you know your your parents
tell you tips and advice but they don't
always take it right so I was like me
slowing down or pausing is my kind of
stuff right
but she was true me taking my time
taking a breath all all of those things
help and I still have to remind my
myself take a breath take your time and
so um
so then one day God talks to me and says
listen you have to talk you have a voice
uh you have a a Ministry at the time I
didn't know what it was and so I was
like well God you can't hear that can
you help me where it must be
then I'll talk because God said no no
you have work to do for me amen and you
have to talk
and so here's what God has done for me
to kind of push me out there
so uh in my 20s I could have been 21.
God gives me a a job a direct
TV call center oh nice perfect job for
you
I was in need of a job this was one of
the only
higher paying jobs wow did you go
through an interview process they were
fine and see at this point I could kind
of tweak things yep and so
um
I don't know why I took this job but I
was like I'm broke I need some some
money so I uh I take the job and of
course you have to speak quickly you
know but see I had been trying to train
myself to take my time and so I would
pause but then it the anxiety came back
and it was like
you have to speak because it's and and
so when someone's calling and they're
ain't they're angry I think I had that
job uh for about six months I was
shocked that I had it that long
did you look forward to going to work I
mean was this like something Dreadful as
well like like I don't have to work
today it can I'm brought back the
anxiety yeah I can imagine because it's
like you have you have to speak people
are not understanding but just you have
to repeat things over and over and over
again so then I'm stuttering and then
people can be mean I mean it's like it's
probably grade school on on crack yes
you know already frustrated with the
situation yeah what'd you say yeah
I'm getting I'm getting cursed
oh no and so I kind of have at it
because so they uh pulled me in office
and say yeah hey yo good foreign
but
and I knew it was coming yeah yeah yeah
you know because they're recording the
cows and stuff so
I got fired and so I kind of have like
I'm surprised I don't have it yeah
you're like this love this is when I'm
still stuttering so
um
so then
um I think
um almost 30. I'm parking for Comcast as
a technician a customer
facing technician so that means I gotta
go to the house and speak to the person
explain how interesting what the problem
is and stuff and so
uh around this this time
um
I'm doing better but I still stutter and
so um so I'm old come to Huntsville
and so uh God comes comes back and say
it's it's time
I'm like it's time to do it
God said you have to tell this and so
he's like you you have to overcome your
peers and so I said all right how are
you all right God so
I said I'ma record and just get my
testimony about
and so um I did this here this series
called this patterning Chronicles oh wow
and it's on it's on you Youtube I think
that was like
2015. baby what's it about it's just me
just uh talking about things you've
learned this is my first time uh
dressing wow that I stuttered on a
public
Forum because keeping in mind I'm still
afraid to to to to record my voice to to
to speak about the things I've gone
through in the past and so uh but I felt
so so comfortable do you know do you
know I love this I I think often times
we all have problems yeah they're all
just in different forms but we all
really struggle with certain things
right yeah and what I found is like
um the struggles that we have
if we can help address them somebody
else can have a blessing because they're
like I deal with that same sort of thing
you know what I mean like like you then
begin to use your your struggle as a
source of help for somebody else yeah
interesting that's true and so as I
guess Target uh the price went on I'm
like man I gotta talk perfect
after the third one I'm like hey if I if
I if I mess up yeah who cares and so God
was telling me this too just talk people
are not concerned with how you with how
you talk right and so I did that and so
I did a health class
this is something heavy now I'm in front
of people
looking at me so
uh I actually messed up in my in my in
my mind I messed up I felt it man I
stumbled over these words and then and
so that was a TV radio host that there
we had be become cool
uh me cooking and I'll catering to that
and so I had offered her a free meal so
uh she goes on the radio and said this
is the best chicken sandwich that I've
ever hey she sent a petty yo to me so he
became cool after that so she uh came
and I didn't notice that the the people
in the in the in the crowd were like
they hugged in me intently not just like
a yeah like what's wrong yeah but the
information yeah they were just like wow
yeah and so after I go to her now I just
have a question are you healthy at this
time like like okay so you've always
kind of had an interest in health issues
eating or like things like that yeah
that all all of that happened uh in
2013. the end of 2012 going into 23rd
2013. so is that is that you when we
were talking off off camera a little bit
you were sharing with me a little bit
about how much you weighed and oh yeah
yeah yeah okay way back then yeah so uh
so now Hess is probably like his is
before covert so this is 2019. and so
um you know it's still kind of affects
me still it's not like I'm cured right
her and I I speak perfectly yeah
so-called so I go to her and I say so
how did I do
she didn't even answer that she said man
that information was so powerful and
I didn't know about this and she is is
like she didn't even address me if
you're thinking or well you know I I
messed up and how did I do it she said
man that's good information I was just
soaking it up and so that was God I
can't stand but you also concerned with
others are not even paying attention
beautiful and so um the weight loss so
the end of 2012
um
my wife I have to give her all of the
credit awesome most often yes every
story behind a good man is literally a
good one it's so true like God knew what
he was doing by placing this you know
help her yes in your world yes so now
I'm a fast forward in combat so she was
actually doing the Huddle hell Challenge
from church
now I didn't know this so I just thought
man she's going on this health tip and
I'm like no I'm gonna keep drinking them
regular milk and I'm gonna I'm Gonna
Keep on eating the meat and stuff I'm
that type of person I'm gonna give a
thousand percent yeah so if I'm like oh
nothing I'm gonna eat meat I'm gonna eat
it all I'm gonna eat the lamb chicken
so when she presented this health thing
that she was on I was killing I'm good
so but I saw her and I saw her
consistency and I'm like man she really
doing this so one day we run out of the
regular milk so I see her soy milk this
is like 2012.
so I'm like man that stuff don't that
don't taste good never tasted it but I'm
just like ah this healthy it don't it
don't taste good so I I said well let me
try it so I took a sip and I'm like
um I don't have a film me after taste I
was like
it don't taste bad yeah which she hate
it because then I decided to drink the
soy milk
and so uh so she's just doing all of
these things she was in white she she's
like I'm not eating meat I'm not eating
Terry you see a physical change yes her
her consistency Sparks something you
know I was still eating the fish and it
seemed like I'm cooking more fish you
know and so but then a thought came why
don't you why don't you try it you know
the soy milk don't taste bad
you know hey why don't you see
so I said all right I'ma stop the meat
because I didn't eat meat all the time
anyways so so I I thought it would beef
uh then chicken then pissed there's an
interesting story about how I stopped
the beef so I was in college and um uh
my my my wife had to come and pick me
pick me up
so on this day I was just super hungry
and me some Helen well was in the food
court I was just like man that Burger
King smells so good flesh and so I had
took the challenge to stop eating beef
hers
but something was just calling me like
Burger King come on come on
so I cut the burger and the fries and a
drink I I get in the car
I didn't offer I didn't buy nothing for
nobody else and I'm just ready to just
tear this thing up
first bite it it literally tasted like
cardboard oh no it had no taste no
flavor it it just didn't taste good
interesting so in my mind I'm like all
right God I see what you did so so I
didn't I didn't eat it and I was like
God okay I'm done it had me I'm I'm
through so then I started having
cravings for chicken
fried baked tenders I mean every farm
and I'm like why am I having oh I I know
what the devil don't want me to change
my diet
so then I I stopped to fish and uh it it
took prayer if it really did uh that's
something that you just can't well you
know and uh then Dairy I was a cheese
person I was like I came back to God
I said I said God oh you are gonna have
to take the taste of cheese out of my
mouth yep and so I did a a pass I did a
fruit pass which is very hard like just
straight fruit just street food for how
long like a week too yeah yeah one week
and it's not like I had this assortment
yeah you had bananas oh
fruits it's great
bananas that's it and so the whole
family is eating regular food
yeah about the third day in you're like
yeah oh my goodness the third day came I
said I had I had to pray like five six
times back to back like oh God my
stomach I want to chew
some food and I was like God please help
me so I I I I get through that I lose 15
pounds wow and I'm like okay okay
my pants sizing kind of went down some
and I'm like all right so I so I had a
juice fast which wasn't as hard
um
still hard though and so I I lost 10
pounds from that
and so uh I'm like man okay so then I
said I'm gonna they will give her the
dairy but I said first I'm gonna take a
quick to Gorge which I do not recommend
overdo it to do that it was cheese it
was sour cream you're going for your
last meal yeah so I'm taking chips and
I'm dipping the sour cream it was just
horrible I still had sour cream after
that week I had to dump out
and I said God I now you just laughing
at me like what are you doing
so so after that I just had on a a
strict plant-based diet wow and how have
you felt I felt great I lost weight I
lost 60 plus pounds oh wow within six
months oh wow and kept it off obviously
yes and the confidence interesting oh
yeah two yeah okay I'm slamming yeah
[Music]
hear the Holy Spirit like we're talking
interesting it was that clear yep and uh
yeah Power powerful does wonders for
your life so you have had a health
interest for a while but you shared with
me you really enjoyed cooking even from
an early kids age so you now have a
catering company called Heaven's healthy
kitchen and this I mean he he brought
some food for us today in the set here
that was amazing I mean literally
everybody sat down and I don't think
anybody said a word for a few minutes it
was just like it's gorging because it
was amazing and and God has really
gifted you a really neat like creative
opportunity to to share your health
interest but through the tasting good
food yeah so this started by um maybe
about six or or seven I used to see mom
um cook like holidays come and she's
making Hammond meringue pie
pecan pie she makes this Special K
loaf amazing tastes like meat and so me
watching her
measure and put it all together and I'm
like man it's so that's so cool so I
went from going in the kitchen to try to
steal probably and uh Hey hate the pole
to now being under her to to high chairs
yeah okay teach me you put a teaspoon
yeah this and that not too much salt and
so from there
I was about eight and I'm and so I began
to create things I created a um
what is now the the
um the actual bill Grande nice I think I
or he just hated that yeah nice sisters
in the 80s
and so I did the uh
the pretty fry beans over the chips and
the cheese and all these things but I I
use thousand island dressing nice which
went perfect with it right and so I
would just begin to create things and
sort of experiment with like yeah like
common things that you know maybe people
are out there but you're putting another
flavor spin on it yeah yeah and so at
the age of 10 I'm now taking over in the
kitchen nice I'm cooking my I'm gonna
come comes home from a hurricane
I make this and this and that
and so
I'm like I want to be a chef wow I I I
want this to be my profile Pro passion
so I go through
um high school and I'm
taking the food that they make you know
I have my own spices that I brought from
home nice and I used to make stuff in
the uh dorms and and so Ramen hotels but
mine's perhaps these vegetables cut up
painted and some little spice to it
adding it yeah and so I just kept this
creative thing going
and so
um so then High School come and this is
so interesting I look back at my at my
uh my gear book
and all of my goals I preached them amen
I said I wanted to but yes have my own
spot yeah uh cater and I mean everything
gonna it's you know and I was like Wow
praise God I've I've done all of these
so I get out of
out of high school
and I'm like okay I'm gonna go off to
school and everything is gonna be great
and it's like uh there's not a lot of
schools for culinary arts and the
closest school was in Pennsylvania
so I'm in in Memphis Tennessee and I'm
like okay I know my parents don't have
money to drive me there or fly me there
and then pay for the school
so I was like well I know how to work so
you know so then time goes goes by and
uh
I think it's like 20 yeah
2013. so I go through the White House
and I'm confident about about that and
so
and so uh I began to go and search for
the ingredients that were plant-based
and I began to see a lot of stuff is not
good it's still it's even in the
plant-based things more so vegan things
so my god um oh yeah this is something
else after the White House I said God I
need substitutes substitutes for cheese
for sour cream for this and for and for
that so I go in the store to look for
these things back in 2013 there was not
a good sour cream so this is not common
stuff that's out there at all 2013. the
cheese maybe Paya which was expensive
back right still is expensive yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah so
um
so and I said well God teach me because
I don't know how to do vegan plant-based
and so and so I went on this journey I
began to hug for vegan
shelves so they're like hey all you got
to do that so there is a true art it's a
plant-based I agree and so I began to
take what I had learned and I began to
create my own things yep so it's like I
went back to the eight year old kid yes
just experimenting shading and putting
things together
so I'm like man this is like my dreams
are coming back
and so um beautiful
that's when Kevin said the kitchen was
created Heaven's healthy kitchen I love
the name and when I first met you
um I remember uh you know just having
some conversations with you you were you
were very outgoing yeah came right up to
me you know and started chatting with me
and stuff and then uh I remember going
to a health event that you were putting
on for it and that was the first time
that I think I had tried your food and
and I was like man this is amazing I
don't remember what it was it was like
some sort of like chili bowler I can't
remember quite what what it was but I
remember walking away from that
experience going it really is a gift and
a talent that you have to make
plant-based food tastes like so full
it's full of flavor and my my brother
Tom is um he's helped start our ministry
and stuff and he's also like really
interested in in health cooking and
those kind of things and I mean you you
guys would be like
he is actually a really talented Chef as
well
he he as a young child wanted to go to
Chef school never did but he's really
interested in sort of this process of
growing the food and then bringing it to
the table but he's he's constantly
coming up with all kinds of
experimentation and he got into freeze
drying food and was like making kale
salad like really yummy kale salad and
then freeze drying it I want to get into
that and when you eat it it's like candy
I mean it's like it's like it's fresh
yeah fresh he would do things like he he
would uh have kiwis freeze-dried kiwis
are amazing and then blend that into the
different types of foods and stuff yeah
meet your brother you do need to meet my
brother in fact if he ever comes out
here I'm gonna personally drive him over
to your house and yeah we're gonna hang
out but um he um
um it's really interesting how most
people when when they talk to you like
you you don't you don't eat meat like
well what do you eat you know you hear
this yeah and and then it's like well
that that I wouldn't want to do that but
there is so many wonderful flavorful
Foods out there and there's so many
things to eat and when you kind of eat
for the health and the taste of it you
know together combined I mean it's
really if let thy food be thy medicine
isn't that what um was it Confucius said
that yeah yeah let that food be thy
medicine and and what a what a neat
thing that God has given to us to share
with each other
it's beautiful all right yeah that's so
true uh because um
because man uh
when I began to get into it you know
I was like this is the art because you
have to really like to put stuff
together
and have it flat paper full so I would
say my my Niche is making it flavorful
not so much salt but have that flavor
kind of yeah pitches yeah yeah and so uh
so you know God is training me because I
don't know this is our who yeah so he
trains me I I I did learn from you from
throwing some research but then God he
be he taught me how to flavor
get get this got him I could be in the
kitchen
baking
no timer the holy spirit will tell me
it's time yeah go get it I could be
boiling something on the stove and and
you know how we second guess guys yes is
that really good what am I making this
mom
so one time Holy Spirit said go go get
your food it's done
boiling and I'm like is this
is
let me test it I went back and my stuff
was was burnt because because I hadn't
waited too long yeah and so I'm I'm in
the kitchen and the Holy Spirit speaks
to me you know you're bringing up an
interesting point that I think that we
need to think about more often because
we kind of treat God as like he's this
busy you know overlord of the of the
universe yeah and he's he's not
interested in these little details but
yet you know we've grown up thinking he
knows all the hairs on my head he knows
all these minute details about you and
and the Bible says you know like he will
direct your past to turn to the writer
to the left right so why wouldn't he be
involved and interested in even those
tiny insignificant details it's this
kind of like pray without can you know
ceasing right you're continually talking
to God and how you do that is through
the work of the Holy Spirit oh yeah when
I was like hearing the Holy Spirit can
and see places after my White House
Journey so I'm not eating out of the
junk and the meat so I can clearly hear
the Holy Spirit speaking I was like this
is amazing the holy spirit is telling me
when my food is done
wow I could have stuff in the oven stuff
on the stove he would say go check it
and I would have to immediately go and
do it and that's how God wants us to
obey him not waiting yeah to obey yeah
but if he say do this or know that he
should move quickly yeah I mean you
think about you know the stories where
food is involved in the Bible right
Jesus after he was died and resurrected
I mean the first thing he does he goes
back to the disciples and he cooks them
a meal on the on the shore right yeah I
mean there's there's exam the first
thing we do when we get to heaven we're
going to have a big meal I mean that's
like you know that's like what they talk
about right somebody gets married here
on Earth what do we do we go celebrate
with a big meal afterwards food is such
an interesting thing and and I think
it's this real intimate thing that God
has designed and um I think it's really
neat that you're in tune with that and
it's like the very God that designed
that I mean it's it's pleasureful right
our minds can can release endorphins and
all sorts of things the flavors burst in
your mouth I mean yeah this is a parent
right you know and and
another interesting thing too is we pray
before we eat yeah and in the Bible
there's even a caution not to eat things
that were sacrificed to the idols
exactly so that I want to tell you that
there's something spiritual oh it's food
as well and it's uh you know we kind of
talked a little bit off too like there's
a movement that uh you go to Los Angeles
now it seems like there's a vegan
restaurant every two feet right yeah but
how much of that is incorporated with
the new age
you go to like some of the best vegan
restaurants and they're Buddhist yeah
have you noticed that oh yeah and so you
know it's interesting that there is a
spiritual element to some of these
restaurants and they have all their you
know spiritual literature that's pushing
their you know like ideas and things
um in connection with food so I think
that you know there's a lot more
complexity things with food than we give
it credit oh yeah yeah yeah food
it's the in uh industry that would ever
go
away yeah it's gonna always Peter and
and so God told me you will forever have
a job you amen people have to eat yeah
so
um that's interesting too um
I was trying or talked to just you know
working out a nine to five work hard you
know I I seen my parents both work even
though my dad wasn't in the um wasn't in
the home but um I saw him Park all the
way up to the here that he died and so
my mom is still working she's she's
working two jobs wow and so I'm like God
Elevate me to a point where I can say
mama you don't have to work right you
know I'm a family man yeah let me build
you a house yeah you know out in the
country yeah nice and so that's that's
my code for it is to you know useful
um just just to spread the health
passage amen which is to serve God to
get your son like your your
um your air your water and to know what
type of what not what type but how much
you should drink every every day so my
goal is not just to cook but to teach
help
and to teach
um people where health comes from
because it comes from God you know third
third time I wish above all things that
thy May prosper and be in health and I I
believe that there are three components
to hell
mental physical and spiritual that's
right and so the spiritual points to God
because he said I want you to be healthy
right in all these components right and
so this is what I push
um at first it was food food
and uh I'm gonna speak speak on the the
name because God gave me that heaven's
healthy kitchen will even be a part of
that I was like uh I don't even think it
had a name I was just making jams and
tellys and the butter and I was mailing
it off to Cali to uh here from other
states
and so a friend a friend of mine said
man I think you should do
this don't worry about a nine to five he
said now talk talk to God to you know
make sure that's in his plans
so I said Okay cool so I go and I pray
and I say God
um what what should I do should I do a
nine to five
or should I do the cooking should I do
both should I do one or the other and
and so God told me he said do the
cooking
sounds like oh okay great what should I
hey man
so he didn't really answer me at that
job so I so
it's so much to the story but I had made
my first
um meal
and so I I put it on Facebook I'm all
excited it's on a pay uh pay a paper
plate it's not fancy I'm not saying I'm
a chef at this at this time I'm so happy
for the White House and the fact that I
made my first meal mac and cheese the
chicken head love it that you had but it
was not that chicken yeah yeah it was so
you've developed it really well yes and
so I took a picture I put up on Facebook
and I was like man that look good
and probably like you should start your
own business and I'm like what that's on
how to hurt you know the cooking and the
business party I said I don't I don't
know so after their friend mentioned
that
and I'm like well let me go ask these
people who've been saying I I should
start my my own thing
so I was like what should I call it oh
my goodness I I started getting crazy
names and I was like now and then one
person said healthy kitchen I'm like
okay that's got a nice little brain to
it so I go back to God I said God um
I kind of like healthy kitchen I said
but what do you want me to call it nice
guy said College Heavens healthy kitchen
I love it I'm wearing this t-shirt
Evan's healthy kitchen this is this is a
really neat story I I think there's not
a person out here that has felt that you
know under under the circumstances I
can't do this or I can't do that and and
to see what you've done with the the
inspiration that God has given you and
to see these dreams that you've had
since you were a young child actually
come to fruition
um and you've gotten really good at it
right
talk about your podcast because now you
started a podcast and you're starting to
really like okay what can I teach other
people tell me a little bit about that
okay so before I get to the uh of I
always wonder why did God tell me to
name it Heaven's Health oh yes okay
and so a person came to me and and said
man the name is too long and I was like
no that's what God gave me I shouldn't
try to make it smaller or just say
healthy kitchen and so uh just out the
blow because I said
this is why I told you to name it
Heaven's healthy kitchen I just thought
God was just adding on the heavens part
because you know heaven so God said
heaven
represents the gospel oh yeah
he said healthy represents the health
message teaching people that that you
need Vitamin D and water and the proper
nutrition
uh and then she said the kitchen is the
cooking and he said it should go in this
order oh wow I was like what
Holy Spirit just he explained it and I
was like
that's why I I will never take that off
and do an abbreviation sometimes I I'll
say hhk right but I'm always putting
Heaven's healthy kitchen right now
because they're represents something
bigger yeah oh that's beautiful and and
you know I'm sure like God's got a lot
more in store for you yes but I think
it's neat that you're taking what you've
learned what you've done and you're
turning around and blessing other people
with that not only giving them physical
food giving them spiritual food I mean
there's so many kind of connections
there with the name like that and yeah
and uh uh you have this podcast that
you've begun that you're now starting to
you know share this information with
other people what's the name of the
podcast it's called A change is going to
come practice I love it a chain now why
would you name it something like that
okay Anderson's story I have a thousands
stories
so my wife once again inspired me she
said I'm gonna have a pie uh podcast I'm
like okay that sounds cool and then the
thought come you should start a podcast
too because I also have a um a Ministry
called help save help save lives through
Christ amen and so that came before
Heaven's healthy kitchen so Kevin said
the kitchen is kind of ah helps a
perhaps the price is the umbrella and so
then comes the uh Heaven's healthy
kitchen
so I was like man God I kind of put that
on the side and so got every so often he
comes and say don't forget them this is
the main thing
and I said well so then God said do a
podcast where you can speak on
everything the gospel
Wellness Health cooking current events
Last Day Events prophecy the Bible is so
much and so then I was like once again
what should I call it
things like boom A change is kind of
come
and I was like yeah that's a change is
coming Jesus is coming we need to be
healthy wellness all of these things
play a important part
and so um if you think about it we are
actually all changing yes you're either
changing for the good or you know you
can easily be on a path that can change
for Destruction and something bad right
yeah but we're all changing all the time
and and so you know to have something
that's like you know God's wanting to
transform you change you I like that
connection there and so at first I was
Kelly why a chain is kind of coming you
know to use this coming back and I'm
like oh
and I was like that fits perfectly and
so I start off with giving my personal
testimony on my speech like that's my
Icebreaker so uh I actually go more into
detail on my pocket on my podcasts and
so um that's the price one there's a
three part to my uh Speech testimony
and um I just did another one like it
just got started cool cool we'll put the
link in the description below in case
any of you guys really want to check
that out
um I encourage you to check it out it's
inspiring I mean I know we've been
chatting a little bit about you know
some of these things that you've
overcome but but honestly like this is
neat to see uh really I think watching
somebody have something like that like
it like uh there's that speaker that
public speaker who doesn't have the arms
and the legs right yeah when you see him
you just immediately go if that guy can
do it I can do it exactly and so
sometimes you know
um it's easy for us to get down on our
situation like God why is this happening
to me why do I have this but maybe
that's to glorify God and maybe that
thing that happened to you is so that
someone else can look at your experience
and say I have a challenge too yeah I've
seen what you've done with it I'm gonna
to give my heart to God and see what he
does with that you know so oh yeah I
think it's really neat to to hear your
story yeah and I think
for for for me I believe it was to
Humble me
because I know if I could talk perfectly
I would I would probably be doing my own
thing and just not even concerned with
others and stuff and and I thank God
um he'll hold it because you know God
doesn't bring up born you know harm or
or or bad things or discomfort on
purpose you know so uh and so God told
me like yeah it was too humble you and
in spite of it
all of these things have happened so
when I look back and I'm and I'm just
like man
I had anxiety I was stressed out my my
dad my husband in the home and kids
picking on me and
and uh that embarrassed them helmets in
high in high school and it's a whole lot
more moments good and bad that's in the
podcast but
I look back like man God is really a
changed the income yep yep I never
thought that I would be speaking on a
camera
being able to answer the phone and not
at a call center freeze up I mean just a
regular phone call I would just be like
oh man I have
I have to speak so quickly and so yeah
God has brought me a long way and he's
given me all the kind it's been a
hundred percent him you know people can
give a price but it was it was it was a
guy like yeah there you go call center
job yeah and I was like why am I here
and then a podcast like but you know
what's so interesting I feel so
comfortable just like I'm here I feel
comfortable I don't feel like oh man I
have to speak right so quickly or I can
take my time in the park the podcast is
is like this is the it's the it's the uh
microphone is the it's the camera and I
feel totally calm comfortable I I never
saw this in a million years I just
thought well I'm gonna just be a in a
interim person but extra fur just spills
out of me and it's like God it's like
come on dude
you have to though yeah you can't battle
this in yeah and both of my parents
extroverts my my mom was speaking camera
tracked out to anybody that's the same
member can have guns yeah she does not
care my my dad that's who uh it's like
I'm half of my parents yeah yeah you
know funny how it works out like that my
mom more extrovert my daddy was an
extrovert too but more laid back and so
I I took on that the most but as I get
older it's like
you're you're you're both of these
you're laid back until you cool with a
group of people or just you
but then I'm I'm I'm not afraid because
God is giving me that com that
confidence to speak to to strangers to
speak here you know to to to
do a podcast you know and so it's just
kind of like man I was like I have both
of my parents character treats I mean
that's so cool that's right that's right
and and you know what a neat thing that
you're going to be doing for the rest of
Eternity when you get to heaven you're
going to be a speaker top shelf
Chef too yeah wait till you taste that
those angels food you know it's gonna be
like this raw apple pie y'all yeah yeah
it's gonna be so good yeah well I look
forward to that table oh Emmanuel thank
you so much for blessing us with you
know your testimony your confidence your
your Warmness your your talent as an
artist to really actually bless other
people with with the things that you've
been interested and learned along the
way but you know thank you for coming on
our show and for those of you that are
out there please check out not only
Heaven's healthy kitchen if you he
caters parties and things so you know in
if you're around the Alabama Huntsville
Alabama area and you need a good vegan
hater that's going to make that food
taste like amazing here's your guy right
here and uh check out his podcast put
the link in the description below A
change is coming and thank you so much
Emmanuel thank you guys for tuning in
like subscribe in this video and share
it with somebody that you may know that
maybe feels like an underdog and they
want to see a story of somebody else
that's been in those shoes and
ultimately remember this Jesus knows
what it feels like to be an underdog I
mean he came down and people made fun of
him like what you're From Galilee what
good is coming out of Galilee and Jesus
did some of the most amazing things on
our planet in fact the Bible says if all
those things are written down in a book
there wouldn't it be even enough books
to record all those things so you know
God's promising that you too can
overcome anything and bless other people
if you if you stay connected to God
thank you for watching and we love you
guys we'll see you next week
[Music]
foreign
there has been very few movies in the
history of the world that have
completely changed our world and in 1999
a movie titled The Matrix hit the world
stage these stories are often told and
seen over and over again is it simply
just to make money
or is there something more nefarious
behind it
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign